the leaders of openai Google deepmind
and several of the top AI Laboratories
issued an open letter that was 22 words
law mitigating the risk of Extinction
from AI should be a global priority
alongside other societal scale risks
such as pandemics and nuclear war I
don't necessarily have a problem with
brevity even in math class it didn't
matter how smart you were you always had
to show your work you had to explain how
you got there these guys of all people
should know that in the best case
scenario it's that they don't agree and
how they got this answer but they all
agree that this is the answer
okay but probably what's more likely is
that they very much know
how they all got this answer
they very much know the role that they
all played in us getting to this point
and they don't want to snitch on
themselves